entramos en la oficina del comisionado
electoral de Pensilvania
desde aquí Omar savir promueve y asegura
la participación de los votantes Lo
mismo hizo los comicios presidenciales
del 2020 y por eso recibió estas
amenazas
en hablar
hace su trabajo con miedo
yo diría con más conciencia y con más
propósito siento que incluso si mi vida
se perdiera por el trabajo que estoy
haciendo merece la pena creo que la
democracia no tiene precio
de priceless pero encontrar 8.500
trabajadores para los más de 1.700
centros de votación no está siendo nada
fácil porque hay miedo los funcionarios
insisten en que la seguridad está
garantizada
hay cosas que es mejor no hacer públicas
pero quiero asegurar que todo el mundo
estará seguro como siempre ha estado
entendemos que hay preocupa estamos al
tanto de eso y estamos trabajando en
ello
imposible que haya fallos en la boleta
Esta es nuestra boleta de prueba Estas
son las máquinas donde ya se está
votando de manera anticipada pero lo
mejor de estas máquinas es que tienes un
recibo de verificación
una garantía de que ninguna boleta se
pierde no seleccionaré ningún candidato
para quienes votan por correo los 18.000
buzones que hay en la ciudad están
controlados por cámaras de
videovigilancia como esta Pensilvania es
un estado clave para determinar el
control del senado y también la futura
agenda política del presidente joeyden
es una de las pocas oportunidades que
tienen los demócratas de quitarles un
escaño a los republicanos pero aquí los
resultados están muy ajustados y la
participación en mayor o menor medida va
a ser decisiva por eso el candidato
republicano trata de ganar votos entre
los latinos pero su agenda electoral no
convence a votantes como Karen ponlo de
inmigración de que están con los de o y
todo eso los afroamericanos también
pueden decidir al ganador porque están
más indecisos que nunca
y así está siendo este comisionado
espera una de las mayores cifras de
participación que se han visto en los
últimos años